- What's up y'all!
We've got Derek Hough here.
We've got Leslie Grace from
"In The Heights" there.
That's right, they're stretching it out.
You want to know why?
Because Derek is a legendary
dancer and Leslie killed it
in her new musical and I'm just, well,
amazing at everything.
So it's time for a game we're calling
"Dance Battle Double Down."
(jazzy dance music)
- [Announcer] (singsong)
Dance Battle Double Down
- Get it Jessie!
You know what Jessie, I
think we're gonna need
another person over here and I pick you.
- You want that?
- [Kelly] Yes, I want that.
- Hold on, let me take my belt off.
- [Kelly] Oh, are you getting,
- Oh, okay!
- [Kelly] Oh, I see.
- [Kelly] You gonna take
your earrings off too?
What's happening?
- [Jessie] I'm gonna
take my shoes off too.
- [Kelly] Are we coming to play, Jessie?
- Let's go, Clarkson.
- [Kelly] All right,
it's going to be Jessie
(audience clapping)
- It's gonna be,
- It's gonna be Jessie and Leslie
versus the winners, Derek and me.
Now we just need a host.
So, God, are you there lord?
- [God] Hey Kelly, I was
just tending to my garden.
You like apples?
I'm just playing.
(group laughs)
- [God] How you doing,
girl, how you doing?
- I am good.
Still a little mad that
I'm not invited in,
but thanks for helping with the game.
So could you tell us how it works?
- [God] Well Kelly, this is
a dance game, so I'm going
to read a question and the
answer to that question
will be the name of a dance.
- Okay.
- [God] Now if you know the
dance, be the first to jump up
on that platform and give the answer.
Now if you're right,
you'll have the chance
to double down for another
point by doing the dance
for my own amusement.
Now, we're going to play in rounds.
Kelly against Jessie and
Derek against Leslie.
Now if Kelly wins, if you
win Kelly, the right side
of our house seats will get
a cool prize, but if not,
the left side will win.
Okay, so let's get Kelly
and Jessie up there first.
C'mon now.
- Oh, wait, it's us first? Oh,
- [God] That's right, that's right.
- Yes, Clarkson.
- Let's do it, let's do it.
- [God] Listen to the voice of God now.
- I took my shoes off, good luck.
- [God] Here is your first question.
- Okay.
- What dance move was pioneered
by Alfonso Ribeiro on the-
- Oh, yes!
- [God] Kelly, what is the name,
- The name of the dance?
- [God] The name of the dance.
- It's not unusual?
- The Carlton.
- [God] It is the Carlton!
Now, for double the points,
can you do the dance?
Let's get some music.
- Said it first.
(instrumental to "It's
Not Unusual" by Tom Jones)
- It's not unusual to be loved
by anyone, bah nah nah nah.
- I said it first!
(Kelly and Jessie yelling)
- [Kelly] I didn't know
if I was supposed to get,
(group chattering)
- [God] All right, all right now
- No I said Carlton, I
said Carlton for the thing,
but then I was like, wait,
is it called the Carlton?
- All right, Leslie.
- [God] All right that's enough now.
C'mon now, Derek and Leslie,
it's your turn, get up there.
- Okay, it's me.
- Go get it.
- [God] Now here's your question.
Derek you look so sexy in that jacket,
let met just tell you.
- Yes, Derek!
- [God] Okay here's your question.
The Terminator, R2-D2, and
Wall-E are examples of what?
(block pings)
- Oh, yes!
- Aw.
- The Robot.
- [God] They are, and
for double the points,
can you do the Robot?
Music please?
- It's like one of these.
(electronic music)
- [God] Get that, that
is, uh, do the Robot.
- Uh, get it.
- [God] Oh, look at that.
- This is how you win.
- [God] That's what I'm talking about.
That is what I'm talking about.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Derek] Yeah!
- [Kelly] Woo!
- [God] That Robot don't
need no oil on those joints,
let me tell you.
Kelly and Jessie c'mon let's
get up there let's go again.
- Okay, bring the bra strap up.
- [God] Here's the question.
- Okay, okay.
- Four to zero, by the way,
so let's get it together.
- [Jessie] Okay, God, thank you.
- [God] Here's the question.
When something totally
unexpected happens in a movie,
you would say it's a plot, what?
- Oh!
(both platforms ping)
- [God] Ooh, we got a, now hold on we got.
- [Jessie] What does that mean God?
- [God] I'ma say it's a dance
off, ladies and gentlemen.
- Oh ho ho.
- [God] We have ourselves
a tie, so it's a dance off.
- Are you ready for my moves?
Are you ready for my moves?
- Do we need support?
- Am I freaking out because
I'm kinda remembering how to do this?
All right, 'Kay.
- [God] So the dance is called,
- The Twist.
- [God] The Twist, and maestro
please, let's see the twist.
Load the alt, uh.
(Rockabilly music plays)
- Oh shoot, that's cuter.
- [Leslie] C'mon, C'mon.
- [God] Oh, yeah, that's
what I'm talking about.
I gotta say, Jessie is the
winner of the Twist dance.
- [Kelly] I gotta say
Jessie is the winner.
- [Leslie] I must say,
(crowd clapping and hooting)
- [Kelly] I'll hand that off.
- [God] Oh hell yes.
Derek and Leslie, it's all you.
- [Kelly] C'mon I'm
losing for us win for us.
- [God] This is it.
We got time for one more.
Here we go now, last question.
- An act of grace, God.
- [God] Here it is, if some
dude is working out very, very
hard on a treadmill,
what would you call him?
- [Kelly] (whispering) It's
the running man, running man.
- [God] You see someone,
(platform pings)
- Now, now hold on, this is
worth triple, by the way.
I'm throwing in a wrench here.
- Please know it, please know it, please!
- [God] Derek?
- Is it the Running Man?
- Yes!
- [God] It is the Running Man!
- Of course it is.
- [God] And for double the points,
can you do the Running Man?
Music, please.
(instrumental to "Can't
Touch This" by MC Hammer)
- [God] There it is, running, uh.
- Yeah!
- Yes!
- Woo!
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Boo, boo.
- Jessie, would you like
to seem my Twist again?
- Boo,
- [God] That is it, here we go, that's it.
That means Kelly and
Derek are the big winners
along with the right side
of the audience, but Kelly,
(audience clapping and hollering)
I know you and I know you
probably want to give the prize
to everybody, so just go ahead,
- Yes, everyone is a winner.
Swig is a fashion
oriented drink ware brand
that offers a variety of
insulated tumblers with designs
that match current trends
and your own personal style.
Everyone in the house seats
is getting a hundred dollar
Swig gift card.
(Kelly making air horn noises)
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Thank you so much
for playing and losing.
(Kelly laughs)
I will say your Twist
is really good Jessie.
Leslie's movie "In The
Heights" is in theaters
staring tomorrow and Derek's
show "High School Musical:
The Musical: The Series"
is on Disney Plus.